[Music]
hello everyone i'm fernando and i'm
excited to announce that i'll be
speaking at the upcoming online api
conference organized by manning this
august i'm going to be covering how to
use redis together with your
microservices to create reactive
architecture i can't wait to be there
see you soon
hi everyone i'm fernando and today we're
going to be talking about uh fan we're
ready it's essentially how to use redis
to create a reactive output architecture
with your micro services like i said i'm
fernando i've been working um with
scalable architectures and the web
platforms in general for the past 18
plus years i've even written a few books
about microservices and scale
architectures as well you can look them
up on amazon and i'm the author of the
upcoming manning book got well with
others
that you can that you can check out if
uh if you're a new developer or you know
someone thinking about getting started
in the in the industry so what are we
going to talk about today um so
essentially i want to sell you on the
idea of
reactive architectures and why what they
are why they're such a great great
approach uh inter-service communication
and how you can use redis to
to create them so let's let's get
started so what is a reactive
architecture let's let's start with the
basics
um a reactive architecture is one that
values uh the client's time overall
uh and by client i mean any any piece of
software that sends a request to a
resource and it's it needs um a response
essentially so on a normal
microservice-based architecture
usually usually through http
the client
would need to
stay locked essentially waiting you know
for that
response
for whatever request it sends so it it
can either just wait there until it gets
there the response or you know times out
uh given certain time or keeps you know
actively pulling the
the resource to see if it's ready
and if
if it's ready to be
retrieved
however
uh on a reactive setup
the client can send the request and just
keep doing something else the server
doesn't need to know about it uh from
the service server's perspective um
nothing changed uh the request needs
this needs the same amount of time
to be fulfilled however from the client
side uh time is optimized why because
following this pizza example uh the
total time or the overall time to get
the pizza that didn't change it's still
the same however in the meantime after
we requested the pizza uh we can just go
and set the table
get some get some drinks call some
friends to
i don't know check up on them and then
get the pizza so we did a lot a lot more
between two and four
that we were able to do before uh giving
our
basic approach at client-side
communication client server
communication
so how does this translate into a more
architectural
point of view uh and essentially
it translates to this so um
to having a producer
um which is essentially a component that
sends an event
uh somewhere and that can however be
used however uh
other sides of this architecture want to
uh the event itself or a message
essentially that contains all the
relevant information that the other side
needs the message bus that is the medium
through which all these uh events travel
from producer to consumer
and then the consumer itself which is
the
bits of logic essentially that reacts to
to the message
there is no
direct communication between
microservices here as you can see
and a very important thing as well is
that not every consumer needs to react
to every
event to every message
this is key to optimize as well
the communication
especially when you have a huge number
of consumers
they can be spread out through different
type of messages and so
we don't want to notify everyone every
single time
so this is essentially a way to use the
observer part on an architecture level
now that we know what
a reactive architecture is um why choose
it why go for it
like i said it helps optimize client
time it helps the client be request
something and be free to do other things
at the same time so while it doesn't
really reduce time overall for a request
for a particular request that's on the
server side that's on the service side
sorry
uh the the
the
client itself is able to um to do
something else to to work on something
else in the meantime
that also uh
from a ui perspective for instance it
makes it fluid it makes it easier to
notify the user what's happening and you
know instead of being locked uh on
waiting something to happen
it also simplifies the multi-service
multi-service requests essentially
complex use cases where a single request
from a client requires multiple
microservices to interact with each
other
on a normal scenario you will have
either to write code on the client side
to orchestrate how many and which micro
services need to interact with each
other
and
or either that or have it have that
orchestration logic uh spread out
through all different all the different
microservices
involved each one knowing uh which one
to call after one after after each other
so uh this approach simplified
simplifies uh that interconnect
communication because
they each service becomes essentially a
consumer
for the clients requests but also a
producer for their own uh events
that other microservices
will pick up on and and start
interacting
uh it's also a lot easier to add new
services uh this is again thinking about
that complex scenario with multiple
microservices interacting with each
other
if you had that orchestration logic
written somewhere
uh adding a new microservice would mean
adding code to that to that logic
uh extended it somehow and however easy
that might be based on however you you
might have structured it it's not it's
not gonna be easier than just
uh not changing any code essentially so
on a reactive approach you don't have to
change code uh adding a new
uh a new microservice
on a
on this type of scenarios you just
create the microservice encapsulate that
logic inside a new service and then have
it uh subscribe to that type of event
maybe one exists already existing uh
which is will be the ideal case or a new
type of them but that would be it
uh the the the other microservices would
need to know which type of event to tr
to produce
that would that would be it at a minor
change a minor modification uh compared
to anything to any other approach
and finally because of this you see how
we can decouple services from each other
so
all the services don't need to know um
if there is anyone else around to be
called or if there is uh where they are
or you know what they have to do with
the data or you know how they require
the data
all they need to care about is the
message bus the rest
is up to however you configure that um
interaction so that's
that's what makes a reactive
architecture so special
of course
was
nothing's perfect there is no
single approach to all type of problems
so it also comes with a few cons
especially and mainly
it's definitely be hard to debug
reactive architecture is a synchronous
by nature and and data can flow in very
different
ways um
so unless you add
some metadata around
uh the
the messages the events so that you can
um
understand which microservices
interacted with with it and how and you
know what they did to that data um
in between you know the client and the
request on their final response then you
can't really um
track everything that happens
that's one thing and the other big thing
is that it requires a change in mindset
microservices we are cons we're very
used to uh client server approaches such
as rest
that uh
simplify a lot the the
communication paradigm between you know
this the starting point and the
end point of that flow whatever happens
on the server that's fine but the the
client is uh aware that it sends our uh
um
a request um
it will just stay there waiting for the
for a response uh on this reactive
paradigm that changes uh it's completely
asynchronous so both client and internal
microservices they need to understand
that and they need to
know
essentially that everything has to go
through them
the message bus essentially
those are the two the two main
[Music]
main changes had to happen uh and
definitely
personally i think they're worth the
trouble
but uh that is something of course that
you have to use and decide at your own
discretion depending on your
your particular use cases
um so
so far we've been talking about um
reactive architectures and hopefully
i'll be able to i i've been able to
sell you on this however
uh we need to now talk about redis and
and
to fi to finalize
um the idea of how easy it is to create
this especially around radius
so if you don't know
already radis is a nosql database uh
that means that
it's there there's no uh enforce schema
to the data you save on it uh there is
no
there are no fields uh or tables uh like
you will find on a sql-based uh database
such as mysql or you know possibly or
oracle any anything like that uh there
are there is no concept of private key
foreign key any kind of relationship
between records um essentially
in red is you say data on using key
value pairs you know uh the key which is
a string and
that acts as the unique identifier for a
record and then the value which is
another basic type such as a number a
string or a list of other basic types
but that is about about it
um
the
the
storage structure is very simple very
basic but the grain the main thing about
red is it's a it's that it's an
in-memory storage
that means uh it's built for performance
uh
writing and reading in memory data it's
a lot faster than getting from disk
around depending on the benchmark and
everything but it's around 20 to 20
times faster
so um
we're talking about you know um
considerably uh high speeds when you
have to
uh
when you have use cases that require a
lot of um
read and
writes
on um on data such as for instance a
typical use case phrase which is caching
so checking if the cache is there
checking reading getting uh that
information and so on it's uh will might
happen uh very often and needs to happen
very fast this is why reddis uh shines
in such scenarios
however as we're gonna be seeing there
is a lot more to radius than just
running and writing data
on memory
so
uh while key value pairs are
essentially based you know the basic
core structure of radis we want to look
a bit beyond that
uh and the two
uh main features already that i want to
cover here that are key in my opinion to
create a reactive architecture are both
pub sub and key space notifications
on one side uh pub sub is a
out of the box
message queue that comes with
um with redis you don't have to do
anything
it's already installed by uh by default
and it can be used simply by
uh
connecting using a different essentially
different method on the client to come
to to connect to it but um so it gives
you access immediate access to a
producer consumer paradigm essentially
what we've been discussing so far about
reactive architectures
and it doesn't the other key here is it
doesn't affect normal vibrations that
means if you're using redis already for
anything cache or whatever uh you were
using it
uh that that's not gonna change it's not
gonna be affected by the pops up
use that you might give it
so
that you have essentially if you have
radish you have that message bus that we
saw before
already there
and the other key thing here that i want
to to highlight is the key space
notifications that feature to me is uh
another fantastic feature from radius
that simplifies even further the the
creation of a reactive architecture so
essentially keyspace notifications are
sort of like a pub sub but
with predefined events right so we
talked about events before we talked
about how the um
producer can choose which events to to
to send which kind of messages to send
on
on the other side the consumers will
pick it up if they wanted to right so um
here is reddit itself acting as a
consumer sending specific specific
events around keys so
events such as delete update or expire
that means if we update a key we can get
notified if we updated a key means
updating a data a value on the storage
uh deleting a key or creating a new key
even uh means saving saving something
new to redis and we get notified
um
in particular the one i'm gonna be also
covering is the expirement which is my
favorite event because it allows you to
um it not only allows you it
completely simplifies uh the
uh the creation of time-based events so
we're gonna be covering that in a second
so but before and to highlight this um
um
you can think of
uh
microservices in a reactive architecture
as independent building blocks or lego
bricks if you will uh on the
and to put an example a very silly and
trivial example look at the site
box on on your screen so we have very
simple save user
function
that will do two things
it will save the user to uh whatever
storage we're using right and it'll
notify um
not notify sorry it'll uh send a welcome
email to that user essentially right
welcome to our application or whatever
um
the code is fine it works but there is a
slight coupling here
because
our function that is in charge of saving
the user into storage medium
is also in charge of sending an email
and that's not something that we want uh
and even if we were to abstract that
send email method into an emotional
notify or welcome user right
uh
the save user function would still be in
charge of orchestrating
uh that logic and here is again the
orchestration um
i said it before
we don't want that in our code as much
as we can because changes in that
orchestration means changing in the code
if we can
move away from that
uh it simplifies the logic a lot so
instead think about splitting those two
you know lines into different functions
as smaller microservices as smaller
lego bricks
on one side you just have the save user
which
saves the user and that's it that's its
whole responsibility and then you have
the welcome user function
that is in charge of sending an email
yes but that's the only thing that is
doing
and through events
uh automatically sent by redis or once
the user is saved
you can uh
connect this or yeah correct connect
these two these two functions these two
logic sections of your code
um
it happens so the notification or the
welcome email happens as a side effect
of you saving a user but you don't
really have to worry about in the future
changing the way you notify the user
so if instead of sending an email you
also want to i don't know send a
whatsapp message all you have to do is
create a new microservice that is um
associated with the same event as a
welcome user function and that's it
then you
there is no need to change any
orchestration logic or there is no need
to add any extra code to uh your
platform
so
that is the the main advantage of
the reactive architecture coupled with
the automatic key space notifications
that you get from redis when in this
case for instance a new
a new records uh is created
and uh finally like i said the
particular use case that um
it's really hard to implement on
reactive architectures are time-based
events uh things like send an email
three days after users is registered to
your app or um you know remind the user
that it's been three days
since uh their last login or even
um
non
user facing uh notifications such as
removing a record after two weeks of not
being accessed that's all uh that's
automatic uh
housekeeping that you can implement
uh through these time-based events the
thing is
um
how can you implement
this type of behavior um
you don't without a reactive approach
you would have to do something like um
periodically running
you know a
potentially heavy script to check for
these logical conditions or even i don't
know acquiring a database every day that
could potentially have millions of
records that translates to processing
power and that also translates to
resource utilization which in the end
also translates to money being wasted
on um
you know days that potentially the end
result the
end result is there's nothing to do
right so
instead of
checking every day for something that
might happen once a week
why not run your code only once a week
and that is but how do you know when and
you know
exact moment that is when uh time-based
events happen and uh we can achieve
team-based events using redis through
key space notifications and ttl so
essentially time to leave on records by
default redis also allows you to when
you whenever you create a record or
update it you can say set
a time to leave for it and when that
timer
goes out uh the record will be uh
removed automatically by redis if you're
also enable if you've also enabled um
keyspace notifications and you have a
consumer waiting on that type of
respon
notification event
then
you suddenly are able to
react to these flags
being removed so if you have
um a record that's not you know that is
being created today you can set a flag
for it uh that will expire into weeks
whenever you update that record you
update the flag and then that flag
that flex time to leave it's reset but
it's if it's been two weeks
without accessing you know updating the
flag without accessing essentially the
record then um that flag will expire and
your record and your trigger will be
sent
and then
your logic can remove that record
so this is what time-based events are
and again they're very
difficult to implement
from a resource consumption point of
view unless you have something like
redis here that is itself
handling all the uh time-based logic
for you so all you carry is that an
event was triggered and
that your logic gets
executed that is all and that is all you
need
with your active architecture the
message bus and time-based events so
to summarize and and and close this uh
this
talk
uh on on the reactive architecture side
you uh you know that you help optimize
the client's uh resources
both time and and
processing resources gets up get
optimized because you use
whatever um
you need to use without having to spend
either time resources waiting or
checking for you know data being
available uh they're easier to extend
because there is no there is
no or very little uh orchestration logic
to modify
uh whenever you have to uh either add
new resource new services or change the
way they interact with each other
again
you can represent the orchestration
through subscription to events that
simplifies everything and essentially
they become building blocks or lego
bricks that you can use to create
different behaviors or even different
platforms altogether
and fridays on top of that
uh simplifies the whole thing the whole
development process because it
it's already coming with a message was
out of the box for you
uh it provides extra events that allow
you to simplify the um event time based
events handling
and if you're already using it which
let's be honest if you have a
big enough architecture you probably use
it to optimize other caching or whatever
other you know fast and and
um
volatile uh records being read read and
written in memory you can already take
advantage of it without affecting
anything that you've done so far and
have a message pass on the key space
notifications to enhance the the way you
interact with it
that's it we're done um i hope that i
want to thank you for for watching and i
hope you got something interesting out
of it out of this
talk
uh if you want to know more
or want to reach out to me uh
for any related topics just use
some of the mediums there listed or if
you found this topic interesting
and you want to follow my radio medium
feel free i write about uh
back-end both back-ends and and
front-end related topics so
you may enjoy that as well
other than that thank you very much
again